49 صوتا مؤيدا مقابل 51 عضوا رفضوا حزمه
المساعدات الجديده
لك الليله ليله حزينه لتاريخ مجلس الشيوخ
ولبلدنا لقد نجح الجمهوريون في عرقله
اقتراح هام جد لارسال المساعدات الى
اوكرانيا واسرائيل وسكان غزه ومنطقه
الهندي
الهادئ جو بايدن كان يامل تقديم هذه
المساعدات قبل نهايه العام
الحالي تصويت اليوم سيبقى في الذاكره
والتاريخ لن يرحم من اذر ظهورهم للحريه لا
يمكننا ان نترك بوتين
ينتصر كل الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ صوتوا
بلا فهم يشترطون تجديد سياسه الهجره مع
المكسيك مقابل تليين موقفهم تجاه
المساعدات لاوكرانيا مساعدات لن تصل الى
كياف التي تقول انها في اشد الحاجه اليها
قبل نتيجه التصويت بقليل الرئيس الاوكراني
تحدث امام قاده دول مجموعه
البح لا تتمنى روسيا سوى امر واحد فقط هو
انهيار العالم الحر العام المقبل تؤمن
روسيا بان الولايات المتحده واوروبا ستظهر
ضعفا ولن تبقي على دعم اوكرانيا بالمستوى
المطلوب تريد كيف حمايه سكانها من بروده
الشتاء القارس وتخشى من استهداف روسيا
لبنيتها التحتيه كما فعلت العام الماضي